sad breaking news the actor Robbie
Coltrane the best known of course for
his roles in Cracker and as Hagrid in
the Harry Potter series has died at the
age of 72 that is according to his agent
in a statement she said my client and
friend Robbie Coltrane ove passed away
on Friday October the 14th Robbie was a
unique talent sharing the Guinness Book
of Records award for winning three
consecutive best actor baftas for his
portrayal of Fitz in the Granada TV
series cracker that was in
1994-95 and 96 with uh Sir Michael
gamble he will probably be best
remembered she said for decades to come
as Hagrid in the Harry Potter films a
role which brought joy to children and
adults alike all over the world
prompting a stream team of fan letters
every week for over 20 years James Bond
fans write two to applaud his role in
Goldeneye and the world is not enough
and she goes on the agent for me
personally I shall remember him as an
abidingly loyal client as well as being
a wonderful actor he was forensically
intelligent brilliantly witty and after
40 years of being proud to be called his
agent I shall miss him he has survived
by his sister Annie Ray his children
Spencer and Alice and their mother Rona
Gamel they would like to thank medical
staff at Fourth Valley Royal Hospital in
Lovett for their care and diplomacy
Robbie Coltrane died today